the Tory party chair says that public
services are in pretty good shape
has the Prime Minister met a single
member of the public who agrees with him
prime minister
Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker because of the
record investment that we're putting
into public services like the NHS we're
now getting waiting lists now because of
the reforms that we've made to our
education system more children are
studying in good and outstanding schools
because
[Applause]
[Music]
he's living in another world to the rest
of us
people waiting more than two days from
an ambulance because they broke the NHS
only one in a hundred rapists going to
court because they broke the criminal
justice system
[Applause]
number of small boats crossing the
channel because they broke the Asylum
system
people can't afford their bills can't
get the police to investigate crimes
can't get a doctor's appointment does
that really sound like pretty good shape
to him yes well
Mr Speaker what's the record since since
2010 since since 2010 crime down by 50
under the conservative government Mr
Speaker 20 000 more police officers
we've given them more powers and we've
toughened up sentencing all opposed by
Sir softy over there
Mr Speaker either the private order
and we considers want to hear the
question and the answers whether one
says your progress questions beyond the
publisher wants to leave early along
with the leader of the opposition help
me to help them yes Mr Speaker either
the Prime Minister doesn't use the same
public services to the rest of us or he
simply can't see the damage they've done
to our country
in 2019 Aria Ali a convicted people
Smuggler through boiling water over a
prison officer leaving him with first
degree burns the prison officer said it
felt like acid his face was on fire
his attacker was found guilty received a
prison sentence quite right in my view
does the Prime Minister agree
well Mr Mr Speaker while record is clear
on sentencing it was this party and this
government that
sentencing act last year it toughened up
sentences and the average custodial
sentence has now increased since 2010 by
almost two-thirds for child sex abusers
is up by 15 months and for rapists it's
up by two years and when our sentencing
act ended ended the automatic early
release of offenders who pose a danger
to the public it was a labor party who
voted against it
[Applause]
well what the problem is prime minister
arieli sentenced ariely's sentence ended
up being suspended yeah and anyone
watching this would wonder why someone
who violently attacks a key worker isn't
Behind Bars
well the court judgment spelled it out
cause it took 16 months for the attacker
to be charged that's ridiculous and it
took another two years before he was
sentenced completely unacceptable
caught the Primus to see that because
they've lost control of the Court
service because they've created the
largest Court backlog on record yes he's
letting violent criminals go free
[Applause]
wait we're cracking down
he's uncomfortable Mr Speaker he's
uncomfortable aggressive we toughen the
law on sex offenders so they spend
longer in prison he voted against it Mr
Speaker
and we've increased rape convictions by
over 60 percent meanwhile he meanwhile
he he attended he attended 21 sentencing
Council meetings the watered down
punishments
that's why they call him sir softy soft
on crime soft on criminals
[Applause]
[Music]
of sex offenders he's just shown he
doesn't understand how the criminal
justice system works no wonder he can't
fix it but and and he thinks that
cracking down on crime is suspending a
sentence where someone should be in
prison that shows the problem and
another reason Mr Speaker another reason
cited by the court for suspending the
sentence in ariali's case was a letter
from the Justice secretary in February
about prison overcrowding
as a result of that letter courts have
been told to have awareness of the
impact of current prison population
levels when passing sentences
in simple terms the Wrecking Ball the
Tories have taken to criminal justice
means that thousands of people who
should be in prison aren't
the court also said it shakes his head
he should read the Judgment the court
also said that is for the government to
say when prison conditions return to a
more normal State now I know the Justice
secretary has been busy trying to save
his own job rather than actually doing
it
but has the promise to ask him when he's
going to get a grip on the prison system
and withdraw that letter which is
allowing criminals to walk free
Mr Speaker we're in the process of
building 20 000 more prison places
that's what this government is
delivering because we're toughening up
sentencing and putting more people
behind bars and making sure that our
most serious offenders spend longer
there but I I love it when he talks
about his record as a lefty lawyer Mr
Speaker because I was looking I was
looking at this because when he was
there I read he's the quoting things I
read that people were really
disappointed that his organization let
down victims
in my assessment that was his shadow
Attorney General
[Applause]
I want to get through these questions so
do my constituents if there's any member
whose constituency aren't interested
please leave the chairman well Mr
Speaker
when I was in office as director of
public prosecutions those benches
migrate to supporters in 2013 the home
Affairs select committee said uh we
would like to commend the work of the
director of public prosecutions Kia
staba he's stripping to improve the
treatment of sexual assault they can
want to say
please
can we
play mission's questions matter to our
constituents
I wonder if I were you it's not the day
I want to get through it because I'm
trying to help the Prime Minister and
the leader you're not being helpful
we'll hear this question number two
how long it takes okay Mr Speaker
this is 2030 order
Miss Stevenson I've heard
I've heard a few weeks this the last
week I suggest you quiet or is better
you leave Mr Speaker this is the home
Affair Select Committee in 2013. they go
on to say the work I did should provide
a model to other agencies or when it
leaves the CPS he will be missed now
that report was presented to Parliament
by the then-home secretary future Prime
Minister the right I'll remember for
maidenhead
and the government those pensions noted
and supported it
now it's obviously always a good look to
have your work recognized although they
did lay it on a bit thick so perhaps
perhaps the primes have spent less time
trying to rewrite history
and why I'm sorting out the messes made
[Applause]
it's just a snapshot of Public Services
collapsing under his wall
wherever they
[Applause]
look trains they
policing mental health Provisions the
Tories have broken them all and all
they've got left is excuses and blends
now I know the Prime Minister would
rather talk about a math lesson than the
state of the country but perhaps it
could solve this equation why after 13
years of a Tory government are patients
waiting longer than ever criminals
walking free growth non-existent and why
everywhere you look just nothing seem to
work at all
yeah
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I I can't I can't
quite remember but I think he started by
talking about when he was DPP
and I'm
I'm actually I'm actually glad he
brought that out because there was
something else that happened when he was
DPP in 2013.
[Applause]
that was when he
shall law Mr Speaker I've got it right
here
but the pension the pensions the
pensions increase
the pensions increased secure stormers
[Laughter]
because I just say it I ordered a eggs
make both sides to listen to the
questions and the answers prime minister
Mr Speaker it here it is it's the the
pensions increase pension screen for
kirst armor QC 2030
well we're in choosing a transformative
policy to support doctors doctors to cut
the waiting list faster he wants to
raise taxes on public sector workers and
it's truly it's one law for him and tax
Rises for everyone else
[Applause]